-- two, one and -- okay.
Here is a lecture on the
applications of eigenvalues
and, if I can -- so that
will be Markov matrices.
I'll tell you what
a Markov matrix is,
so this matrix A will
be a Markov matrix
and I'll explain how they
come in applications.
And -- and then if I have time,
I would like to say a little
bit about Fourier series, which
is a fantastic application
of the projection chapter.
Okay.
What's a Markov matrix?
Can I just write down a typical
Markov matrix, say .1, .2, .7,
.01, .99 0, let's
say, .3, .3, .4.
Okay.
There's a -- a totally just
invented Markov matrix.
What makes it a Markov matrix?
Two properties that
this -- this matrix has.
So two properties are --
one, every entry is
greater equal zero.
All entries greater
than or equal to zero.
And, of course, when
I square the matrix,
the entries will still
be greater/equal zero.
I'm going to be interested
in the powers of this matrix.
And this property, of course,
is going to -- stay there.
It -- really Markov matrices
you'll see are connected
to probability ideas and
probabilities are never
negative.
The other property -- do you
see the other property in there?
If I add down the columns,
what answer do I get?
One.
So all columns add to one.
All columns add to one.
And actually when I
square the matrix,
that will be true again.
So that the powers
of my matrix are all
Markov matrices,
and I'm interested
in, always, the eigenvalues
and the eigenvectors.
And this question of
steady state will come up.
You remember we had steady
state for differential equations
last time?
When -- what was
the steady state --
what was the eigenvalue?
What was the eigenvalue in
the differential equation case
that led to a steady state?
It was lambda equals zero.
When -- you remember that
we did an example and one
of the eigenvalues was lambda
equals zero, and that --
so then we had an E to the
zero T, a constant one --
as time went on, there
that thing stayed steady.
Now what -- in the powers case,
it's not a zero eigenvalue.
Actually with powers of a
matrix, a zero eigenvalue,
that part is going
to die right away.
It's an eigenvalue of
one that's all important.
So this steady state
will correspond --
will be totally connected with
an eigenvalue of one and its
eigenvector.
In fact, the steady state
will be the eigenvector
for that eigenvalue.
Okay.
So that's what's coming.
Now, for some reason
then that we have to see,
this matrix has an
eigenvalue of one.
This property, that the
columns all add to one --
turns out -- guarantees
that one is an eigenvalue,
so that you can actually
find the eigenvalue --
find that eigenvalue of a Markov
matrix without computing any
determinants of A
minus lambda I --
that matrix will have
an eigenvalue of one,
and we want to see why.
And then the other thing is --
so the key points -- let me --
let me write these underneath.
The key points are -- the key
points are lambda equal one is
an eigenvalue.
I'll add in a little --
an additional -- well,
a thing about eigenvalues --
key point two, the other
eigenval- values --
all other eigenvalues are, in
magnitude, smaller than one --
in absolute value,
smaller than one.
Well, there could be some
exceptional case when --
when an eigen -- another
eigenvalue might have magnitude
equal one.
It never has an eigenvalue
larger than one.
So these two facts --
somehow we ought to --
linear algebra ought to tell us.
And then, of course, linear
algebra is going to tell us
what the -- what's -- what
happens if I take -- if --
you remember when I solve --
when I multiply by A time
after time the K-th thing is A
to the K u0 and I'm asking
what's special about this --
these powers of A, and very
likely the quiz will have
a problem to computer s- to
computer some powers of A or --
or applied to an initial vector.
So, you remember
the general form?
The general form is
that there's some amount
of the first eigenvalue
to the K-th power
times the first eigenvector,
and another amount
of the second eigenvalue
to the K-th power
times the second
eigenvector and so on.
A -- just --
my conscience always makes me
say at least once per lecture
that this requires a
complete set of eigenvectors,
otherwise we might not
be able to expand u0
in the eigenvectors and
we couldn't get started.
But once we're started
with u0 when K is zero,
then every A brings
in these lambdas.
And now you can see what the
steady state is going to be.
If lambda one is one --
so lambda one equals one
to the K-th power and these
other eigenvalues are smaller
than one --
so I've sort of scratched
over the equation there to --
we had this term, but what
happens to this term --
if the lambda's smaller than
one, then the -- when --
as we take powers, as
we iterate as we --
as we go forward in time, this
goes to zero, Can I just --
having scratched over
it, I might as well
scratch right? further.
That term and all the other
terms are going to zero
because all the other
eigenvalues are smaller than
one and the steady state that
we're approaching is just --
whatever there was -- this
was -- this was the --
this is the x1 part of un- of
the initial condition u0 --
is the steady state.
This much we know from
general -- from -- you know,
what we've already done.
So I want to see why -- let's
at least see number one,
why one is an eigenvalue.
And then there's actually --
in this chapter we're interested
not only in eigenvalues,
but also eigenvectors.
And there's something special
about the eigenvector.
Let me write down what that is.
The eigenvector x1 --
x1 is the eigenvector and all
its components are positive,
so the steady state is
positive, if the start was.
If the start was -- so --
well, actually, in general, I --
this might have a -- might have
some component zero always,
but no negative components
in that eigenvector.
Okay.
Can I come to that point?
How can I look at that matrix --
so that was just an example.
How could I be sure -- how
can I see that a matrix --
if the columns add to zero
-- add to one, sorry --
if the columns add to one,
this property means that lambda
equal one is an eigenvalue.
Okay.
So let's just
think that through.
What I saying about -- let
me ca- let me look at A,
and if I believe that
one is an eigenvalue,
then I should be able to
subtract off one times
the identity and then I would
get a matrix that's, what, -.9,
-.01 and -.6 --
wh- I took the ones away and
the other parts, of course,
are still what they were, and
this is still .2 and .7 and --
okay, what's --
what's up with this matrix now?
I've shifted the matrix,
this Markov matrix by one,
by the identity, and
what do I want to prove?
I -- what is it that I
believe this matrix --
about this matrix?
I believe it's singular.
Singular will -- if A
minus I is singular,
that tells me that one
is an eigenvalue, right?
The eigenvalues are the
numbers that I subtract off --
the shifts --
the numbers that I subtract
from the diagonal --
to make it singular.
Now why is that matrix singular?
I -- we could compute
its determinant,
but we want to see a reason
that would work for every Markov
matrix not just this
particular random example.
So what is it about that matrix?
Well, I guess you could
look at its columns now --
what do they add up to?
Zero.
The columns add to
zero, so all columns --
let me put all columns
now of -- of --
of A minus I add
to zero, and then I
want to realize that this
means A minus I is singular.
Okay.
Why?
So I could I -- you know,
that could be a quiz question,
a sort of theoretical
quiz question.
If I give you a
matrix and I tell you
all its columns add to
zero, give me a reason,
because it is true, that
the matrix is singular.
Okay.
I guess actually -- now what --
I think of -- you know, I'm
thinking of two or three ways
to see that.
How would you do it?
We don't want to take
its determinant somehow.
For the matrix to
be singular, well,
it means that these three
columns are dependent, right?
The determinant will be zero
when those three columns
are dependent.
You see, we're -- we're at
a point in this course, now,
where we have several
ways to look at an idea.
We can take the determinant
-- here we don't want to.
B- but we met singular
before that --
those columns are dependent.
So how do I see that those
columns are dependent?
They all add to zero.
Let's see, whew --
well, oh, actually, what --
another thing I
know is that the --
I would like to be able to show
is that the rows are dependent.
Maybe that's easier.
If I know that all
the columns add
to zero, that's my
information, how
do I see that those three
rows are linearly dependent?
What -- what combination of
those rows gives the zero row?
How -- how could I combine
those three rows --
those three row vectors to
produce the zero row vector?
And that would tell me
those rows are dependent,
therefore the columns
are dependent,
the matrix is singular, the
determinant is zero -- well,
you see it.
I just add the rows.
One times that row plus one
times that row plus one times
that row --
it's the zero row.
The rows are dependent.
In a way, that one one one,
because it's multiplying
the rows, is like an
eigenvector in the --
it's in the left
null space, right?
One one one is in
the left null space.
It's singular because
the rows are dependent --
and can I just keep
the reasoning going?
Because this vector
one one one is --
it's not in the null
space of the matrix,
but it's in the null
space of the transpose --
is in the null space
of the transpose.
And that's good enough.
If we have a square matrix
-- if we have a square matrix
and the rows are dependent,
that matrix is singular.
So it turned out that the
immediate guy we could identify
was one one one.
Of course, the --
there will be somebody
in the null space,
too.
And actually, who will it be?
So what's -- so --
so now I want to ask
about the null space of --
of the matrix itself.
What combination of
the columns gives zero?
I -- I don't want to compute
it because I just made up this
matrix and --
it will -- it would
take me a while --
it looks sort of doable because
it's three by three but wh-
my point is, what --
what vector is it if we
-- once we've found it,
what have we got that's in
the -- in the null space of A?
It's the eigenvector, right?
That's where we find X one.
Then X one, the eigenvector,
is in the null space of A.
That's the eigenvector
corresponding to the eigenvalue
one.
Right?
That's how we find eigenvectors.
So those three columns
must be dependent --
some combination of columns
-- of those three columns is
the zero column and that --
the three components in that
combination are the eigenvector.
And that guy is
the steady state.
Okay.
So I'm happy about the --
the thinking here,
but I haven't given --
I haven't completed it
because I haven't found x1.
But it's there.
Can I -- another thought came
to me as I was doing this,
another little
comment that -- you --
about eigenvalues
and eigenvectors,
because of A and A transpose.
What can you tell me
about eigenvalues of A --
of A and eigenvalues
of A transpose?
Whoops.
They're the same.
They're -- so this is a little
comment -- we -- it's useful,
since eigenvalues are
generally not easy to find --
it's always useful to know some
cases where you've got them,
where --
and this is -- if you
know the eigenvalues of A,
then you know the
eigenvalues of A transpose.
eigenvalues of A
transpose are the same.
And can I just, like,
review why that is?
So to find the eigenvalues of A,
this would be determinate of A
minus lambda I equals zero, that
gives me an eigenvalue of A --
now how can I get A transpose
into the picture here?
I'll use the fact
that the determinant
of a matrix and the determinant
of its transpose are the same.
The determinant of a matrix
equals the determinant of a --
of the transpose.
That was property
ten, the very last guy
in our determinant list.
So I'll transpose that matrix.
This leads to --
I just take the matrix
and transpose it,
but now what do I get
when I transpose lambda I?
I just get lambda I.
So that's -- that's all
there was to the reasoning.
The reasoning is that
the eigenvalues of A
solved that equation.
The determinant of a
matrix is the determinant
of its transpose, so that
gives me this equation
and that tells me
that the same lambdas
are eigenvalues of A transpose.
So that, backing up
to the Markov case,
one is an eigenvalue of A
transpose and we actually found
its eigenvector, one one one,
and that tell us that one is
also an eigenvalue of
A -- but, of course,
it has a different
eigenvector, the --
the left null space isn't the
same as the null space and we
would have to find it.
So there's some vector here
which is x1 that produces zero
zero zero.
Actually, it wouldn't be that
hard to find, you know, I --
as I'm talking I'm
thinking, okay,
I going to follow through
and actually find it?
Well, I can tell from
this one -- look,
if I put a point six there
and a point seven there,
that's what -- then I'll be
okay in the last row, right?
Now I only -- remains
to find one guy.
And let me take the
first row, then.
Minus point 54 plus point 21 --
there's some big number
going in there, right?
So I have -- just to make
the first row come out zero,
I'm getting minus
point 54 plus point 21,
so that was minus point 33
and what -- what do I want?
Like thirty three hundred?
This is the first time in
the history of linear algebra
that an eigenvector has
every had a component
thirty three hundred.
But I guess it's true.
Because then I multiply by minus
one over a hundred -- oh no,
it was point 33.
So is this just -- oh, shoot.
Only 33.
Okay.
Okay, so there's
the eigenvector.
Oh, and notice that it -- that
it turned -- did turn out,
at least, to be all positive.
So that was, like, the theory
-- predicts that part, too.
I won't give the
proof of that part.
So 30 -- 33 --
point six 33 point seven.
Okay.
Now those are the ma- that's
the linear algebra part.
Can I get to the applications?
Where do these Markov
matrices come from?
Because that's -- that's part of
this course and absolutely part
of this lecture.
Okay.
So where's -- what's an
application of Markov matrices?
Okay.
Markov matrices --
so, my equation, then,
that I'm solving and studying
is this equation u(k+1)=Auk.
And now A is a Markov matrix.
A is Markov.
And I want to give an example.
Can I just create an example?
It'll be two by two.
And it's one I've used
before because it seems
to me to bring out the idea.
It's -- because we have two
by two, we have two states,
let's say California
and Massachusetts.
And I'm looking at the
populations in those two
states, the people in those
two states, California
and Massachusetts.
And my matrix A is going to
tell me in a -- in a year,
some movement has happened.
Some people stayed
in Massachusetts,
some people moved to
California, some smart people
moved from California
to Massachusetts,
some people stayed in
California and made a billion.
Okay.
So that -- there's a matrix
there with four entries
and those tell me the
fractions of my population --
so I'm making --
I'm going to use fractions,
so they won't be negative,
of course, because -- because
only positive people are
in- involved here -- and
they'll add up to one,
because I'm accounting
for all people.
So that's why I have
these two key properties.
The entries are
greater equal zero
because I'm looking
at probabilities.
Do they move, do they stay?
Those probabilities are
all between zero and one.
And the probabilities add
to one because everybody's
accounted for.
I'm not losing anybody, gaining
anybody in this Markov chain.
It's -- it conserves
the total population.
Okay.
So what would be a
typical matrix, then?
So this would be u, California
and u Massachusetts at time t
equal k+1.
And it's some
matrix, which we'll
think of, times u California
and u Massachusetts at time k.
And notice this matrix is
going to stay the same,
you know, forever.
So that's a severe
limitation on the example.
The example has a --
the same Markov matrix,
the same probabilities
act at every time.
Okay.
So what's a reasonable, say --
say point nine of the people
in California at time k
stay there.
And point one of the
people in California
move to Massachusetts.
Notice why that
column added to one,
because we've now accounted for
all the people in California
at time k.
Nine tenths of them are
still in California,
one tenth are here at time k+1.
Okay.
What about the people
who are in Massachusetts?
This is going to multiply
column two, right,
by our fundamental rule of
multiplying matrix by vector,
it's the -- it's the
population in Massachusetts.
Shall we say that -- that
after the Red Sox, fail again,
eight -- only 80 percent of the
people in Massachusetts stay
and 20 percent
move to California.
Okay.
So again, this
adds to one, which
accounts for all people in
Massachusetts where they are.
So there is a Markov matrix.
Non-negative entries
adding to one.
What's the steady state?
If everybody started in
Massachusetts, say, at --
you know, when the
Pilgrims showed up or
something.
Then where are they now?
Where are they at time
100, let's say, or maybe --
I don't know, how many
years since the Pilgrims?
300 and something.
Or -- and actually where
will they be, like,
way out a million
years from now?
I -- I could multiply --
take the powers of this matrix.
In fact, you'll -- you would --
ought to be able to figure out
what is the hundredth
power of that matrix?
Why don't we do that?
But let me follow
the steady state.
So what -- what's my starting --
my starting u Cal, u Mass at
time zero is, shall we say --
shall we put anybody
in California?
Let's make -- let's
make zero there,
and say the population
of Massachusetts is --
let's say a thousand
just to -- okay.
So the population is --
so the populations are zero
and a thousand at the start.
What can you tell me about
this population after --
after k steps?
What will u Cal
plus u Mass add to?
A thousand.
Those thousand people
are always accounted for.
But -- so u Mass will start
dropping from a thousand and u
Cal will start growing.
Actually, we could see -- why
don't we figure out what it is
after one?
After one time step, what are
the populations at time one?
So what happens in one step?
You multiply once by that
matrix and, let's see,
zero times this column -- so
it's just a thousand times this
column, so I think we're
getting 200 and 800.
So after the first
step, 200 people have --
are in California.
Now at the following step, I'll
multiply again by this matrix
-- more people will
move to California.
Some people will move back.
Twenty people will
come back and, the --
the net result will be that the
California population will be
above 200 and the Massachusetts
below 800 and they'll still add
up to a thousand.
Okay.
I do that a few times.
I do that 100 times.
What's the population?
Well, okay, to answer
any question like that,
I need the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors,
right?
As soon as I've --
I've created an
example, but as soon
as I want to solve
anything, I have
to find eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of that matrix.
Okay.
So let's do it.
So there's the matrix
.9, .2, .1, .8 and tell
me its eigenvalues.
Lambda equals -- so
tell me one eigenvalue?
One, thanks.
And tell me the other one.
What's the other eigenvalue --
from the trace or the
determinant -- from the --
I -- the trace is what
-- is, like, easier.
So the trace of that
matrix is one point seven.
So the other eigenvalue
is point seven.
And it -- notice that
it's less than one.
And notice that that
determinant is point 72-.02,
which is point seven.
Right.
Okay.
Now to find the eigenvectors.
This is -- so that's lambda
one and the eigenvector --
I'll subtract one from
the diagonal, right?
So can I do that in light
let -- in light here?
Subtract one from
the diagonal, I
have minus point one
and minus point two,
and of course these are still
there.
And I'm looking for its --
here's -- here's --
this is going to be x1.
It's the null
space of A minus I.
Okay, everybody sees
that it's two and one.
Okay?
And now how about --
so that -- and it --
notice that that
eigenvector is positive.
And actually, we can jump
to infinity right now.
What's the population
at infinity?
It's a multiple -- this is
-- this eigenvector is giving
the steady state.
It's some multiple of this, and
how is that multiple decided?
By adding up to a
thousand people.
So the steady state, the
c1x1 -- this is the x1,
but that adds up to three,
so I really want two --
it's going to be two thirds
of a thousand and one third
of a thousand, making
a total of the thousand
people.
That'll be the steady state.
That's really all I need
to know at infinity.
But if I want to
know what's happened
after just a finite
number like 100 steps,
I'd better find
this eigenvector.
So can I -- can I look at --
I'll subtract point
seven time -- ti-
from the diagonal and I'll get
that and I'll look at the null
space of that one and I -- and
this is going to give me x2,
now, and what is it?
So what's in the null space of
-- that's certainly singular,
so I know my calculation
is right, and --
one and minus one.
One and minus one.
So I'm prepared
now to write down
the solution after 100 time
steps.
The -- the populations
after 100 time steps,
right?
Can -- can we remember
the point one -- the --
the one with this two one
eigenvector and the point seven
with the minus one
one eigenvector.
So I'll -- let me --
I'll just write it above here.
u after k steps is
some multiple of one
to the k times the
two one eigenvector
and some multiple of point seven
to the k times the minus one
one eigenvector.
Right?
That's -- I --
this is how I take -- how
powers of a matrix work.
When I apply those powers to
a u0, what I -- so it's u0,
which was zero a thousand --
that has to be corrected k=0.
So I'm plugging in k=0 and I get
c1 times two one and c2 times
minus one one.
Two equations, two
constants, certainly
independent eigenvectors,
so there's a solution
and you see what it is?
Let's see, I guess we already
figured that c1 was a thousand
over three, I think -- did we
think that had to be a thousand
over three?
And maybe c2 would be --
excuse me, let --
get an eraser --
we can --
I just -- I think
we've -- get it here.
c2, we want to get a
zero here, so maybe we
need plus two
thousand over three.
I think that has to work.
Two times a thousand over
three minus two thousand
over three, that'll give
us the zero and a thousand
over three and the two thousand
over three will give us
three thousand over three,
the thousand.
So this is what we approach --
this part, with the point
seven to the k-th power
is the part that's disappearing.
That's -- that's
Markov matrices.
Okay.
That's an example of
where they come from,
from modeling movement of
people with no gain or loss,
with total -- total
count conserved.
Okay.
I -- just if I can
add one more comment,
because you'll see Markov
matrices in electrical
engineering courses and often
you'll see them -- sorry,
here's my little comment.
Sometimes -- in a lot of
applications they prefer
to work with row vectors.
So they -- instead of -- this
was natural for us, right?
For all the eigenvectors
to be column vectors.
So our columns added to
one in the Markov matrix.
Just so you don't
think, well, what --
what's going on?
If we work with row vectors and
we multiply vector times matrix
-- so we're multiplying
from the left --
then it'll be the then we'll
be using the transpose of --
of this matrix and it'll be
the rows that add to one.
So in other textbooks,
you'll see -- instead of col-
columns adding to one,
you'll see rows add to one.
Okay.
Fine.
Okay, that's what I wanted
to say about Markov,
now I want to say something
about projections and even
leading in -- a little
into Fourier series.
Because -- but before
any Fourier stuff,
let me make a comment
about projections.
This -- so this is a comment
about projections onto --
with an orthonormal basis.
So, of course, the basis
vectors are q1 up to qn.
Okay.
I have a vector b.
Let -- let me imagine -- let
me imagine this is a basis.
Let -- let's say I'm in n by n.
I'm -- I've got, eh,
n orthonormal vectors,
I'm in n dimensional space
so they're a complete --
they're a basis --
any vector v could be
expanded in this basis.
So any vector v is some
combination, some amount of q1
plus some amount of q2
plus some amount of qn.
So -- so any v.
I just want you to tell
me what those amounts are.
What are x1 -- what's
x1, for example?
So I'm looking
for the expansion.
This is -- this is
really our projection.
I could -- I could really
use the word expansion.
I'm expanding the
vector in the basis.
And the special thing about the
basis is that it's orthonormal.
So that should give me a
special formula for the answer,
for the coefficients.
So how do I get x1?
What -- what's a formula for x1?
I could -- I can go
through the projection --
the Q transpose Q, all that --
normal equations, but --
and I'll get --
I'll come out with
this nice answer
that I think I can
see right away.
How can I pick --
get a hold of x1 and get these
other x-s out of the equation?
So how can I get a nice,
simple formula for x1?
And then we want to see, sure,
we knew that all the time.
Okay.
So what's x1?
The good way is take the inner
product of everything with q1.
Take the inner product of that
whole equation, every term,
with q1.
What will happen
to that last term?
The inner product -- when -- if
I take the dot product with q1
I get zero, right?
Because this basis
was orthonormal.
If I take the dot product
with q2 I get zero.
with q1 I get one.
So that tells me what
x1 is. q1 transpose
v, that's taking
the dot product,
is x1 times q1 transpose
q1 plus a bunch of zeroes.
And this is a one,
so I can forget that.
I get x1 immediately.
So -- do you see
what I'm saying --
is that I have an
orthonormal basis,
then the coefficient that I
need for each basis vector is
a cinch to
find.
Let me -- let me just --
I have to put this into
matrix language, too,
so you'll see it there also.
If I write that first equation
in matrix language, what --
what is it?
I'm writing -- in
matrix language,
this equation says I'm taking
these columns -- are --
are you guys good at this now?
I'm taking those columns times
the Xs and getting V, right?
That's the matrix form.
Okay, that's the
matrix Q. Qx is v.
What's the solution
to that equation?
It's -- of course, it's
x equal Q inverse v.
So x is Q inverse v,
but what's the point?
Q inverse in this case
is going to -- is simple.
I don't have to work to
invert this matrix Q,
because of the fact that the --
these columns are orthonormal,
I know the inverse to that.
And it is Q transpose.
When you see a Q, a square
matrix with that letter Q,
the -- that just triggers --
Q inverse is the
same as Q transpose.
So the first component, then --
the first component of
x is the first row times
v, and what's that?
The first component
of this answer
is the first row of Q transpose.
That's just -- that's
just q1 transpose times v.
So that's what we
concluded here, too.
Okay.
So -- so nothing Fourier here.
The -- the key ingredient
here was that the q-s are
orthonormal.
And now that's what Fourier
series are built on.
So now, in the
remaining time, let
me say something
about Fourier series.
Okay.
So Fourier series is --
well, we've got a
function f of x.
And we want to write it
as a combination of --
maybe it has a constant term.
And then it has
some cos(x) in it.
And it has some sin(x) in it.
And it has some cos(2x) in it.
And a -- and some
sin(2x), and forever.
So what's -- what's the
difference between this type
problem and the one above it?
This one's infinite,
but the key property
of things being
orthogonal is still
true for sines and cosines,
so it's the property that
makes Fourier series work.
So that's called
a Fourier series.
Better write his name up.
Fourier series.
So it was Joseph Fourier
who realized that, hey, I
could work in function space.
Instead of a vector v, I
could have a function f of x.
Instead of orthogonal
vectors, q1, q2 , q3,
I could have orthogonal
functions, the constant,
the cos(x), the
sin(x), the s- cos(2x),
but infinitely many of them.
I need infinitely
many, because my space
is infinite dimensional.
So this is, like, the moment
in which we leave finite
dimensional vector spaces and go
to infinite dimensional vector
spaces and our basis --
so the vectors are
now functions --
and of course, there are so
many functions that it's --
that we've got an infin-
infinite dimensional space --
and the basis vectors
are functions, too.
a0, the constant function one
-- so my basis is one cos(x),
sin(x), cos(2x),
sin(2x) and so on.
And the reason Fourier
series is a success
is that those are orthogonal.
Okay.
Now what do I mean
by orthogonal?
I know what it means for two
vectors to be orthogonal --
y transpose x
equals zero, right?
Dot product equals zero.
But what's the dot
product of functions?
I'm claiming that whatever
it is, the dot product --
or we would more likely use
the word inner product of, say,
cos(x) with sin(x) is zero.
And cos(x) with
cos(2x), also zero.
So I -- let me tell you
what I mean by that,
by that dot product.
Well, how do I
compute a dot product?
So, let's just remember
for vectors v trans-
v transpose w for vectors,
so this was vectors,
v transpose w was
v1w1 +...+vnwn.
Okay.
Now functions.
Now I have two functions,
let's call them f and g.
What's with them now?
The vectors had n
components, but the functions
have a whole, like, continuum.
To graph the function, I
just don't have n points,
I've got this whole graph.
So I have functions --
I'm really trying
to ask you what's
the inner product
of this function
f with another function
g?
And I want to make it parallel
to this the best I can.
So the best parallel is to
multiply f (x) times g(x)
at every x --
and here I just had
n multiplications,
but here I'm going to
have a whole range of x-s,
and here I added the results.
What do I do here?
So what's the analog of
addition when you have --
when you're in a continuum?
It's integration.
So that the -- the dot product
of two functions will be
the integral of
those functions, dx.
Now I have to say -- say,
well, what are the limits
of integration?
And for this Fourier series,
this function f(x) --
if I'm going to have -- if that
right hand side is going to be
f(x), that function that
I'm seeing on the right,
all those sines and cosines,
they're all periodic, with --
with period two pi.
So -- so that's what
f(x) had better be.
So I'll integrate
from zero to two pi.
My -- all -- everything -- is
on the interval zero two pi now,
because if I'm going to use
these sines and cosines,
then f(x) is equal to f(x+2pi).
This is periodic --
periodic functions.
Okay.
So now I know what --
I've got all the
right words now.
I've got a vector space, but
the vectors are functions.
I've got inner products and
-- and the inner product gives
a number, all right.
It just happens to be an
integral instead of a sum.
I've got -- and that -- then I
have the idea of orthogonality
--
because, actually, just
-- let's just check.
Orthogonality -- if I take
the integral -- s- I --
let me do sin(x) times cos(x) --
sin(x) times cos(x) dx
from zero to two pi --
I think we get zero.
That's the differential of
that, so it would be one half
sine x squared, was that right?
Between zero and two pi --
and, of course, we get zero.
And the same would be
true with a little more --
some trig identities to help
us out -- of every other pair.
So we have now an
orthonormal infinite
basis for function space,
and all we want to do
is express a function in that
basis.
And so I -- the end of my
lecture is, okay, what is a1?
What's the coefficient --
how much cos(x) is there
in a function compared
to the other harmonics?
How much constant
is in that function?
That'll -- that would
be an easy question.
The answer a0 will come out
to be the average value of f.
That's the amount
of the constant
that's in there,
its average value.
But let's take a1
as more typical.
How will I get -- here's the
end of the lecture, then --
how do I get a1?
The first Fourier coefficient.
Okay.
I do just as I did
in the vector case.
I take the inner product
of everything with cos(x)
Take the inner product of
everything with cos(x).
Then on the left --
on the left I have -- the inner
product is the integral of f(x)
times cos(x) cx.
And on the right,
what do I have?
When I -- so what I -- when I
say take the inner product with
cos(x), let me put it in
ordinary calculus words.
Multiply by cos(x)
and integrate.
That's what inner products are.
So if I multiply that
whole thing by cos(x)
and I integrate, I get
a whole lot of zeroes.
The only thing that
survives is that term.
All the others disappear.
So -- and that term is a1 times
the integral of cos(x) squared
dx zero to 2pi equals -- so this
was the left side and this is
all that's left on
the right-hand side.
And this is not zero of
course, because it's the length
of the function squared, it's
the inner product with itself,
and -- and a simple calculation
gives that answer to be pi.
So that's an easy integral
and it turns out to be pi,
so that a1 is one over pi times
there -- times this integral.
So there is, actually --
that's Euler's famous formula
for the -- or maybe
Fourier found it --
for the coefficients
in a Fourier series.
And you see that it's
exactly an expansion
in an orthonormal basis.
Okay, thanks.
So I'll do a quiz review on
Monday and then the quiz itself
in Walker on Wednesday.
Okay, see you Monday.
Thanks.